Netflix has a bad habit to kick.
And that habit can be summed up in one word:
"SMOKIN!"
After a recent report revealed that depictions
of smoking in its original content have tripled
in just the last year, the streamer has declared
that they will adopt a new, much more restrictive
policy in regard to such depictions going
forward.
The move comes just days after the release
of the third season of the hit series Stranger
Things, which happens to feature a ton of
era-appropriate smoking.
"Yeah, company policy is a real drag."
The report was released by Truth Initiative,
a non-profit organization that tracks the
appearances of tobacco products in major media.
It's not the first time that the organization
has had occasion to call out Netflix, or even
Stranger Things, for that matter.
A similar report released in March 2018 took
the streamer to task for featuring 182 "smoking
incidents" across the ten episodes which comprised
the show's first season, with other original
offerings such as House of Cards and Orange
is the New Black also coming under fire.
The earlier report also pointed out the troubling
fact that streaming services which aren't
bound to the same content standards that govern
traditional broadcast television are extremely
popular among young people ages 15 to 24,
an age group coveted as potential customers
by tobacco companies.
The new analysis pointed out that the trend
of featuring characters who light up on a
regular basis hasn't just continued, it's
exploded:
"Based on estimated viewership of these programs,
results suggest that approximately 28 million
young people were exposed to tobacco through
television and streaming programs in these
most popular shows alone.
That exposure is a significant public health
concern."
When the issue first reared its head last
year, Netflix issued what could be described
as a non-response:
"While streaming entertainment is more popular
than ever, we're glad that smoking is not.
We're interested to find out more about the
study."
This new missive, however, appears to have
gotten the streaming giant's attention.
As viewers were watching Stranger Things'
police chief Jim Hopper puffing away throughout
the latest batch of episodes, Netflix was
putting together a detailed statement, which
it released to Entertainment Weekly.
It read, in part,
"Netflix strongly supports artistic expression.
We also recognize that smoking is harmful
and when portrayed positively on screen can
adversely influence young people.
Going forward, all new projects that we commission
with ratings of TV-14 or below for series
or PG-13 or below for films, will be smoking
and e-cigarette free except for reasons of
historical or factual accuracy.
For new projects with higher ratings, there'll
be no smoking or e-cigarettes unless it's
essential to the creative vision of the artist
or because it's character-defining (historically
or culturally important)."
The statement also revealed that, in addition
to making a concerted effort to cut down on
the butts, there would be changes forthcoming
to its content warnings.
"Starting later this year, smoking information
will be included as part of our ratings on
the Netflix service so our members can make
informed choices about what they watch."
After nearly two decades of steadily falling
numbers, use of tobacco products among teens
has recently spiked.
To be clear, nobody is pinning the spike on
Netflix.
The reason for the surge is the soaring popularity
of e-cigarettes such as the Juul, which have
seen an explosion in use by teens and young
adults while the numbers for combustible cigarettes
have remained about the same.
It's worth noting that the decades-long drop
in the number of teen smokers came during
a time when references to tobacco products
were being carefully stripped away from broadcast
television.
So it's certainly possible that the more smoking-friendly
streaming services which now field more original
series than broadcast networks for the first
time ever could contribute, in some small
way at least, to a plateauing or even a reversal
of the trend.
Stranger things have happened.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.